hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
dark video that follows Jonah's Khan
Wald's path through time in seasons 1 &
2
I started this months ago after season 2
came out when I was making dark videos
and while I was going through my last
rewatch to make my season 2 recap I
filled in all the gaps to finish it up
since we'll be starting at the beginning
of when we first meet yonas up until the
season 2 finale this video will be
filled with spoilers if you aren't
caught up with the entire dark series
the earliest point we observe in
Eunice's life is in 2019 on the day
before his father Michael Campbell
commits suicide
June 20th we see him wake up at home and
head to the lake to hang out with his
friends there we see him find the st.
Christopher pendant in the sand at the
beach as he sits with Martin Nielsen who
is not his girlfriend but they
definitely are interested in each other
later that night at a party at the
Nielsen's house these two will have sex
for the first time even though he
awkwardly leaves here telling her that
he has to go help his grandmother set up
her tablet after his father commits
suicide
yonus goes away for two months getting
psychiatric treatment which we don't see
it all on screen his friend bartosh
covers for him telling the other
students that he was away in France when
he gets back we learned that he takes
antidepressants works with Peter Doppler
for support and is somewhat haunted by
his father's memory
while he's away Marta gets into a
relationship with that friend bartosh
which creates some additional
awkwardness for him when he returns to
school on the night of November 4th
yonas and his friends head to the caves
where Mikkel Nielsen gets separated from
the others and disappears from the 2019
timeline after that yonus finds a map of
the caves in his father's painting
studio he Bizet's the caves later but
doesn't find anything on his own he
visits his father's grave outside the
church where he's approached by his
older self
yonus has no idea that he is talking to
himself at this point in the story
though later at home he finds a box
containing that futuristic hand lamp we
see him using all the time a Geiger
counter and his father's suicide letter
he looks at that map he
again and notices that now it's been
edited with instructions to follow the
signal when he goes back to the caves he
finds a metal ring and a red string and
he's able to put things together enough
to navigate his way to the metal SiC
moondust door he opens it and passes
through using the passage to time-travel
to 1986 when he arrives there he meets a
younger version of his mother right away
riding around with his paternal
grandfather he searches for Mikkel
intending to bring him back he meets a
young urban tena and has an interaction
with older Egon Tiedemann at the
hospital he sees Mikkel talking to a
younger version of his grandmother he
ends up getting talked out of bringing
Mikkel back by his older self who
arrives to tell him that if he does that
he'll be erasing his own existence at
that point that's enough for him and he
returns to 2019 through the caves there
he talks to his mother asking her if she
believes in fate and then he burns the
version of the suicide letter that came
in the box he tries to reject Martha who
he finds waiting for him outside his
house now he knows that she's his aunt
but he's in this position where he can't
actually tell her the truth she kisses
him which has an effect but he ends up
leaving her in the rain saying he's
sorry he visits his grandmother and he
gets the letter from his father which is
surprising to him at the time because he
just burned a copy of that a few days
before he rages on her a bit for letting
things happen the way they did before he
leaves he gets into a fight with bartosh
outside the school and then he heads
home he looks around his father's
painting studio and when Hannah asked
him what's going on he says everything
will be all right after that he travels
back to 1986 and this is the point where
he becomes a missing person in the 2019
timeline he tries to go visit Mikkel at
the hospital in order to bring him back
but he's abducted by Noah and Helga that
are waiting there they lock him in the
bunker and then the stranger comes to
visit him revealing that he is his older
self and that he's experienced the same
conversation before only on the other
side of the door after that a wormhole
opens in the bunker he reads
is in and touches hands with young Helga
and travels to 2052 when he arrives
there he's knocked out by a person we
learned later as sylia who was an
associate of older Elizabeth months
later we see him listening to tapes that
Claudia made trying to figure out how to
travel back to 20 20 to stop the
apocalypse he's collecting materials and
he finds the time machine but he needs
fuel to make it work after he gets that
he gets caught entering the dead zone
and is almost hanged by Elizabeth who at
the last minute decides to imprison him
instead this is where he gets the next
car that he has for the rest of the
series
sylia frees him because she wants to
know what older Elizabeth is hiding they
go back to the power plant where he's
able to use the fuel to stabilize the
god particle and he leaves 20:53 he ends
up in 1921 where he meets a young noah
and sees agnes as an even younger child
he goes to the cave to try to leave this
time period but learns the passage
hasn't been completed yet then he's
taken to meet adam who reveals himself
to be the oldest version of jonas that
we see his older self tells him he can
change things if he stops his father
from committing suicide he shows him his
god particle machine which is under the
church and sends him back to 2019 on the
day before his father commits suicide
so back in 2019 his timelines overlap
he spotted by the Nielsen's on his way
to the lake and Mikkel delivers the
ultimate fist-bump line again to him at
the beach he steps in and impersonates
himself to tell Martha that they're
perfect for each other and kiss her when
his other self leaves this is funny
because I mentioned earlier that they
have sex for the first time that night
in that situation he thinks that she
made the first move at the party because
of this we find out it was him that set
it in motion but it's comical how it all
plays out and so both characters think
the other made the first move he goes to
meet with Michael to try to stop him
from committing suicide only to learn
that he wasn't considering it Michael
also tells him that it was him who led
him into the caves the night he traveled
to 1986 older Claudia arrives to make
sure Michael takes his life and tells
Yanis she's seen the world with
and it's not what he thinks at this
point he starts to listen to Claudia
instead of Adam because he lied to him
essentially yonas travels back after
leaving him there and at this point we
have a gap in the timeline we know he
spends a year with Claudia but we don't
know any of the details about where they
were or when they were but we do see
when he comes back that his hair is
longer and the scar on his neck is
healed the next time we see him he's
arriving at middle Claudia's apartment
right after she let her father die he
tells her that things don't have to go
that way the next time and tells her
that they need to go he takes her to the
caves and tells her that the big things
and small things don't follow the same
rules he says they can change the grand
scheme of things but the details saying
we change a grain of sand and with that
the whole world he collects some cesium
and he activates the time machine in the
passage reopening it telling Claudia he
is connecting the past to the future
after that he takes her to 2020 he tells
her to go find her daughter and take
Regina to the bunker so that they can
survive the apocalypse he then goes back
to his home where he's reunited with
Marta briefly Adam arrives and he
watches her die after he shoots her and
then he stays with her after Adam leaves
an alternate version of Marta arrives
from a different world using a different
time machine we haven't seen yet and she
transports him away as the apocalypse is
unfolding this is the end of the season
and the last time we see the younger
yonas we won't be able to find out where
they went until we get to see season 3
one of the biggest mysteries related the
Jonases journey through time is how he
becomes the stranger and then how later
the stranger becomes Adam for what it's
worth I am in the camp of fans that
believe Adam is Jonas and not one of the
other characters I arrive there by
playing out the other options to their
conclusions and for me even though it
would be a twist if he turned out to be
bartosh or Michael I don't think it
would improve the story I think learning
how he evolved into Adam makes for a
more interesting story and that's all I
really need to say about it in this
video we don't know much about where he
was before he returns to London as the
stranger in season 1
I think it's a good guess that he spent
some time in alt Marta's world since he
leaves with her but there's still a lot
of unaccounted time when he does return
he rents a room at Regina's Hotel where
he hangs things all over the walls
he eventually leaves saying he wants her
to hold the room for him and asked her
to send the box containing the letter
and the lamp to his younger self he
never returns
so she collects the materials and ends
up turning them over to Charlotte and
Claussen when they come to visit her
after that we see him go to the
graveyard and meet his younger self
which we saw the other way around
and he goes and edits the map in
Eunice's room he collects some cesium
and then travels back to 1986 to stop
his younger self from trying to bring
Mikkel back from the hospital after that
he visits tan house to talk about time
and he gives him the broken time machine
to get it fixed he returns later to
collect it with ten house telling him
that it's the same device in a different
condition he says it's like seeing the
beginning and the end of something at
the same time he then has the
conversation with his younger self in
the bunker before going to the caves to
attempt to destroy the portal he then
travels to 2020 and returns to his
childhood home where he interrupts a
possible suicide attempt by his mother
though he doesn't see her with a gun
pointed at her throat he explains who he
is and he proves it to her by showing
scar on his arm that he got as a child
and talking about a burn mark on the
floor by the stove
he takes his mother back to 1987 so she
can see Mikkel living with her future
mother-in-law when they return they fill
Charlotte in on what's going on and
later bring Katarina in as well at one
point he sneaks into Marta's room and
places the st. Christopher medallion on
her pillow after that his mother steals
the time machine from his room while
he's asleep and she travels in search of
Ulrich stranger yonus is reunited with
martha briefly when she comes to the
house he tells her who he is and they
talk but they get interrupted when
Katarina arrives later he'll force her
into the bunker at gunpoint trying to
save her from her fate but she winds up
escaping when Peter and Elizabeth
arrived back at the house younger Noah
arrives and gives him a letter
he says was written by Marta we don't
see what it says but after he reads it
he leaves with a time machine that
Katharina had left there earlier when
she learned that the portal in the caves
had reopened he goes and he finds Magnus
bartosh and Francisca at the Nielsen's
house and travels with them narrowly
escaping the apocalypse we don't see
where they go
but can guess they eventually wind up in
1921 which is where we meet atom and we
see a confirmed older Magnus there as
well most of what we see in atoms
timeline takes place inside the church
we know that he had younger noah kill
who i presume is an older bartosh and
that he and older noah are trying to
find the missing pages from the
triquetra notebook
he has older noah kill older claudia and
retrieved those pages and that leads to
Noah learning that Charlotte is his
daughter that he's been searching for
anna meets with his younger self Jonas
telling him who he is
and somewhat vaguely what he's trying to
do he says they're waging a war against
time and he recruits his younger self to
travel back to 2019 telling him he can
fix everything if he stops his father
from committing suicide of course he is
actually sending him to set things in
motion for the suicide to happen but he
chooses not to tell him the truth
because Noah has realized Adam knew
about Charlotte the whole time and kept
that from him
he tries to kill Adam but it doesn't
work out when he fails adam has Noah's
own sister Agnes kill him instead
then Adam travels through the god
particle machine at the church to the
day of the apocalypse June 27th 2020
this is where he kills Martha in front
of his younger self saying that Jonas
has to experience that pain in order to
become him he walks out of the house and
that is the last time we see him I
assume he returns to the church and
travels back to 1921 but we'll have to
wait until season 3 comes out to know
for sure and that wraps up yonas con
Wald's journey through time in dark
seasons 1 & 2 I expect that we'll be
getting an announcement about season 3
and a trailer any time now and I
couldn't be more excited I'm gonna end
this video here but I will be back with
more dark videos while we wait for
season 3 to come out please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my
if you're a fan of the show if you have
any questions about seasons one or two
leave them in the comments let me know
your theories about what's going to
happen in season three and thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon